good afternoon councilors and those
joining us on the interweb uh welcome
into this meeting of the community
well-being committee
um
we have an apology from mayor Clark
who's moving between the zone five and
six meeting and Rural provincial
uh and nobody joining us on Zoom
um and no issues of public forum that
I'm aware of but we do have a very
important task
and I'll ask a deputy mayor Tom Campbell
to come and take a monofinoa
Representatives through their oath
so uh
so
all other members no they have already
sworn of their collusion
pursuant to schedule seven plus fourteen
of the Local Government Act
at the last council meeting we agreed
that
um the the two monofino Representatives
would continue to attend
um Council and therefore it's
appropriate that they they also make
that a declaration so what we're going
to do is to begin with is that I plan
your first to come up and she can do as
rest as we've done and read the
appropriate
declaration so can you please come up
[Music]
okay
I declare that I will faithfully and
partially and according to the best of
my skill and judgment execute and
perform in the best interests of the
invercargill city the powers authorities
and duties vested in or opposed upon
me as a representative of tirunner or
awaroa to the invercargill city council
by virtual of the Local Government Act
2002 the local government official
information and meetings act 1987 or any
other Act
thank you
congratulations yeah so then you get a
second
which is actually
it's the old fishing
thank you very much
restarting one
foreign
[Music]
foreign
information
foreign
thumbs up watching
signing his life away
no background this way victory
okay I'll email those to you bye
thank you Dan paparazzi
[Applause]
uh councilors before we move on I forgot
to put a motion with regards to the
apology for mayor Clark
moved Grant second to Alex put that all
in favor I'd still carried any
Declarations of interest that anybody
has to share with us Lotto winnings
hence for Powerball this weekend no
it brings us on to the uh temporary
alcohol bin for Christmas at the races
uh Trudy in the absence of Jillian do
you want to take us through this
thank you Mr chair uh so for those of
you uh first time on this committee one
of the delegations you have is being
able to invoke a temporary alcohol ban
uh we have the Christmas at the races
the meeting on the Saturday the 10th of
December you'll see from the report that
it's recommended by police and the
organizers as it helps control and
maintain a great event for all plus
support our local residents I'm happy to
take any questions
so what's being proposed with regards to
the temporary alcohol ban is that any
different to what we've done in previous
years Trudy no no different to previous
years
thanks to recommendations
happy to move those chairs and Reverend
cook
any questions or comments
you can see the land speed record at
this rate if not I'll put the motion all
in favor I Against
Kerry thank you for that
Caroline if you'd like to come up the
South and sports field strategy
two I was basically just giving you an
overview that we're developing a
Southland Sports field strategy
um which is there to help us understand
the future demand and the capacity and
give us some medium-term planning in
this area uh collaboratively across
Southland
um we've found that one of the emerging
issues we have is consistent data
captures made it very hard for us to do
this um aging to long-term planning
um and looking at our participation
rates from codes and even in gender so
we're just looking forward to getting
this data together the asset management
that we will undertake following this
data Gathering and the report
um May uh May alter we may be looking at
our levels of service but that will be
subsequent to the Southland strategy
being completed
thanks Carolyn can you tell me who the
leaders on the project
um it is just hang on a second of those
Recreation Sport and Leisure
so we've got the three Tas funders
active South and all parties in the
governance group
councilors any questions subscribe yeah
just with regard to the paper is there a
time frame remember in the strategy will
be complete because of sports clubs I
think I'm looking for clarity around
what it's going to look like so
uh the Southlands yeah
it's under it's underway at the moment
um I'm sorry I haven't got that data
with me I'm just going to see if my
colleague Chris has got the end date
yeah
all right
okay so for those of you who didn't hear
that we actually we haven't got a
specific end date on this due to the the
data capture thing so once we can
support the clubs to get the data
together so that we have enough
information that's when the strategy
will be completed it's not ongoing it'll
be within the next six to 12 months so
that'll be completed
honey what type of data sets that you
kept showing is it just in it's it's
participation rates a utilization how
those fields are being used uh the
genders the ages
um the codes everything is it's absent
at the moment honey so yeah
Alex
um just to um add to
um Perhaps Perhaps for um Council Doom
of these uh
context
um and we at the end of last year
um received uh the drug well a copy of
the um spaces and places strategy and
that has a bit of as I understand a bit
of information in there for sports clubs
as to what we intend to do regionally
with spaces but um it's also just about
to be able to come up again for review
so we can receive that information again
or the review of the spaces and places
strategy ideally before we go into ltp
planning
um with an updated version in a bit more
supplementary information alongside the
data capture yeah too much points Sports
need Clarity around when they're going
to know what's going to happen to your
clubs I know of clubs that are planning
potential investment in grounds and
across sporting different sporting codes
but they could get gazumped by the
strategy or it could be advantageous to
them so yeah I think we need to give
them Clarity around when are they going
to know what the strategies around their
Sports field yeah councilor Germany if I
can just give you Surety we are working
alongside them with the clubs they they
know that this is happening and then
we're doing it with them not to them
so we are working with the community on
this but when will we be complete
I'll give the answer just before
thank you chair
um look I'm a bit concerned with the
lack of data and and the compilation of
data because we look to the next item
and I don't want to jump the gun with uh
Splash Palace and I was obviously the
encouragement of rangatahi to
participate
more and swimming the age group of 14 to
23 now I imagine that age group makes up
quite a large proportion of users of
sports Fields now are we going to do a
strategy of what currently is and
realize that no one's playing sport
because obviously if if people aren't
swimming I'd say the same attitude
towards playing sport is is similar
um and are we going to suddenly go out
and commission a report to try and get
people to play sport and then we've done
this with our fields on the current
information I mean it's a chicken and
egg situation are we
are we going to actually find if we find
that young people are no longer playing
sport what are we going to do just
factor that in we need less fields or
are we going to actually do something to
try and encourage people to place for it
I mean we're obviously doing that in the
next agenda item going out trying to
work out why people aren't using Splash
Palace in this age group I'm just
worried that we're going to end up with
a strategy that is purely based on
statistics and that's going to be it so
counselor it's a bit of a chicken and
egg thing I've already mentioned the
chicken I'm a bit worried about the egg
being scrambled thanks
um
certainly sport New Zealand has
indicated in recent years that the
number of participants in organized
sport across the country south and
included is in Decline
and I guess the best way to understand
what the effect is and where we need to
be focusing resources but is by actually
going through this process so this is
the chicken
before we get to the egg yeah but my
question is once we realize there aren't
people participating you're presuming
the outcome yeah what are we going to do
are we going to do what the Vodafone
report's done
or we're just going to take the
information and just say that's it and
we're going to pause and then be
proactive
and trying to get more participants I
mean that's you've got two reports here
one after the other that uh very similar
very similar and um so the council has
the resource in the reserves we don't
organize nor encourage people into the
various sports that's
the responsibility of each code
but we need to better understand what
kind of demand that's likely to be on
the resource
the information that's gathered from
this will also be shared in amongst the
other participants and I guess that
helps them for their planning as well
from our purpose it's how much Reserve
have we got allocated to different
sports is that still fit for purpose
and we can't
uh suppose
that um that it has gone backwards in
some senses there was a decline maybe
it's come forward we don't know until we
get the
the statistics back in
then we can get to the egg
Alex
uh thank you Mr Chi you've pretty much
covered off everything that I was going
to say but um
just to preface my comments um I'm
certainly not a conflict but I do sit on
the border back to Southland there's no
way um pecunery interest here at all but
our strategy largely focuses
um on rangatahi participation and
sporting code as well as just generally
being active every day because we know
that that's got um fantastic benefits
for mental health uh well-being and that
right across the community rather than
just Sports code specific but to um
Council ladlow's point the whole point
of the South and sports field strategy
and widely the regional spaces and
places
um strategy is so that we can understand
all of the data everything that we have
right across the board and pool
resources in some instances and put
things you know because we we know like
a participation is declining then um you
know we're going to have to make some
calls and cut the cost a little bit
along the way
um sporting codes also realize that
they're going to have to do the same
things there will be bowling clubs that
probably have to consolidate there will
be rugby clubs that may even have to do
the same it's um things like that that
will actually enable us to have that
information to feed into our long-term
planning to feed into those
conversations that are being led from
the community up like
um Carolina said we are working with the
community upwards rather than forcing
something down onto them
got a reverend cook Mrs Curtin impact
ring
thank you Mr chair I'm
a couple of things about this
um
we're targeting existing active sporting
codes
who's assessing the use by people the
flex Roots use because I know
um
in my personal experience there's a lot
of
organizations that
um or not organizations groups of
Inferno that use the spaces
and formally
and that's not what not necessarily be
captured by this
the other thing is that
I think we
also need to look at the changing way
that we operate as a society and joining
clubs is beyond the means of a lot of
people so therefore that's where a lot
of these Flats Works type activities
come in how do we help them because they
still have the needs for grounds they
might not
um get to use the club rooms but if I
reflect back to many years ago when I
was a child marching never had
facilities
they used existing fields
um the only time we ever used a
structured place was say rugby park or
um Donovan park for for bigger marching
events so how many more other sporting
activities or recreational activities
perhaps is a better way of
describing it uh operating in that more
ad hoc or more flexible way and are they
going to be captured by this survey
before I come to Bounty of Caroline
you're able to answer that and for more
use question yeah the informal use will
not be captured during this specific
report
because look so further to that then Mr
chair should we be asking
um
not so much our officers but through our
offices to active South and all those
organizations to think about how they
can survey
that
um less less formal but very important
recreational use of our facilities I
understand it's being done what has been
done
uh just some of the two um cancer the
credit in regards to
um usage I mean we know that you know
our Maori will continue to have a
youthful population so you we need them
actually utilizing sports and recreation
where possible
and if we're really looking at health
and well-being I mean that's the best
I think Avenue for us to
um improve the health of our community
so
my position on it
thanks ringy
completely different
topic but the same agenda item rugby
park and sorry Park they're both Sports
field so I guess they're included
yeah yeah okay so obviously in the
strategy and the usage of that we've got
a long-term plan budgeting for those two
areas now obviously
what we go ahead and do there would
would make sense if we knew
um but more about the strategy because
obviously if we if we find out
no one wants it or there's a lot of
people going to be using it then what we
invest in sorry Park and in rugby park
would need to reflect that so again
obviously the delivery of this report
and then working it all out
um I'm not sure when when are we
spending money on those two other areas
sorry Park
they'll be coming back through the
long-term plan yeah I know but we've got
them you know they are scheduled
okay so with that with that time in with
that
would that make sense
through you Mr chair
um counselor because it's a regional
strategy it's not just limited to
invercargill so it may find and I
absolutely make no promise that other
authorities may need to contribute to
Regional spaces such as those you have
mentioned but we won't know that until
we've seen the outputs from the strategy
but I might suggest in perhaps to the
officer would you be comfortable with
also in the interim doing an interim
report back to the committee as to where
things are at yeah as soon as we've got
anything that's more meaningful than
I've got before me right now I'll
definitely promote I was purely worried
about things progressing on those new
areas absolutely so and that might I
think if we can provide you some extra
information it may be able to support
that
catch them soon Alex
thanks Mr chair may I also suggest just
the circulation of the spaces and places
recirculation of the spaces and places
strategy uh for the benefit of all
members
because it already has quite a lot of
information in it um pertaining to these
venues
yeah so through your chair
um I should have raised it earlier when
you were actually talking about the
subject but I've been Keen of pondering
it so apologies for dragging it back
um but I think the point about some
Sports field being used as general
Recreation areas if I can call it that
is actually a very important one in this
context because
um there are some sports fields that I
can think of you know soccer Parts I
have played on which are a long long way
from other public parks
um and of course there are some sports
Fields but actually right next to you
know Queen's Park or whatever and well I
don't quite know how you build that sort
of thing in your survey like this I
think it will be appropriate when we see
those severe results when you see that
report to be asking those questions
um because certainly
um some perks if you use them for other
purposes of Italian matter because of
the field next door there's some other
parts if you use it for another purpose
there'd be nowhere else for kids to play
as it would be nowhere else for anybody
to you know walk the dog so I think that
the point that I think um Evelyn first
made I think is very is a very important
one actually this is not only at the end
of the day when we think about the
subject it can only be in a context of
you know rugby soccer and so forth so
it's more General I mean they value
those those areas
as I understand it that is the intention
and from the participants it goes wider
than us as well um certainly the funding
organizations will find from a regional
perspective that um that information
crucial to how they allocate funds
Alex is at semaphore or absolutely that
is exactly why the funders are also in
The Advisory Group because when they are
considering all the sporting codes or
the additional supplementary Community
groups that they that receive funding if
it's the best use of funds going into
the future
cool I think we've taken it as far as we
can at this stage and we're receiving
the report we're going to recommend that
staff bring back an interim report at
our February meeting and
um essentially that uh a full report is
provided back once the strategy has been
undertaken I'll move there's a second
Anya thanks any further questions or
comments
if not I'll put the motion all in favor
carried and thank you for the points
that are being raised thanks Caroline
right the next subject's been touched on
Stephen do you want to come up and take
the hot seat
Splash Palace rangatahi engagement
barriers
councils I'll take this report as read
and just open the floor to discussion or
any questions
um I read this with some interest
because it's something that I'm quite
passionate about getting kids that are
involved there I'm not quite sure what's
been planned you know when it talks
about hot food or facility for kids
don't we need more than that
I mean are we expecting them to be
involved with swimming or are there
activities related to the pool
through UGA so it's it's a it's the
overall package
um that's sort of enticing them in so
um
the orangutahi uh
um food sort of one thing like they want
hot food so they'd rather go at the
moment go and park up in the Kmart
building and get some food then attend
Splash pallets for you know any
recreational sort of activities
um so price point is one of them and
it's trying to attract that price point
to get them into the door to participate
through each year I know socially
um water polo has always been a magnet
you know for for some
um teenagers I'm just wondering if we
can look to do something you know
similar to yet another group of um you
know students engaged on something like
that because I know
you know my experience
um with water polo it's become a very
social thing where the kids could meet
and talk and and they hang around for a
while so that's is that what you're sort
of envisaging
uh through YouTube so it's it's one
thing that we can do and we're doing
have a go days with some of the clubs
that use Splash Palace so we recently
just had one with underwater hockey yeah
and it's around getting the schools
involved and participating because
there's no
um Youth League of underwater hockey in
the south end at the moment
thanks very much Tom
yeah so
I I wanted a Twitter I mean I always
hate the idea to
um it reinvent the wheel and I just as a
as a nobody in the country who already
does this very well that we can
copy it I mean I have
two thoughts I suppose one is that
um I wonder whether it's just a reality
or a life that between the age of 14 and
20.
um teenagers get involved in other
things
right rather than going to the swimming
pool and that seems a little bit
fatalistic but you know I have that I've
been certainly added so so you you
wonder whether you're um pushing out a
pill but that but the main question I
had to suppose was are we already aware
of other facilities New Zealand who do
this much better than we do
um others everybody
not managed to attract 10 News uh
through you uh chair the these a lot of
facilities in New Zealand and I've
networked with a lot of facilities
throughout New Zealand are having
similar problems just like we all
experience the same problems through
covert uh we are experience a drop in
that um 14 to 23 year old age group
but other ideas being floated by
elsewhere
um this is one of the parts of the
um the report that we've had done was to
get those that was engaged specifically
with rangatahi
so
great yeah so what what are the numbers
in terms of the drop
um
through YouTube so there's no specific
numbers
um related to the 14 to 23 year old age
group that we have specifically
um so we don't know what the dropper
numbers has been
no we just know there's it's been an
issue for a very long time right and so
to stick in the back in the door so
second question mark reading this
uh the question I had is are we trying
to confuse two things I can mend
um you know this the staff are looking
at ways to try and engage Youth and
provide a place where they feel
comfortable and can socialize and
achieve the outcomes they want to within
that age group I think that's great my
question is is the swimming pool the
best place for that and why I ask that
is when you think about a lot of people
that use the swimming pool it's families
it's older people those sorts of things
and what will be the implication of if
we get a lot of use going there on the
existing users and
are we trying to sort of solve two
problems
that as a result we create more problems
and
so I wonder whether we need to step back
and look at okay what do youth want in
terms of that socialization process
and then is the swimming pool a part of
a strategy around where you go connect
and do those sorts of things but it is a
wider strategy as opposed to just trying
to shoot all them into go to Splash
Palace and get your Social connection
but as an outcome of that we
you know we um the existing users
um and even just the shared catering for
them might become very problematic uh
through each year so this is just the
very start of this work so there's a lot
of more work to be done more engagement
to be done
um we can utilize the youth Council as
well to go to schools and and harness
their ability to engage with with those
um
we we're also looking at Splash Palace
around times that would not conflict
with
um families and and the older
demographics
just as a reminder we did invest heavily
in Youth and Family with the Hydra
slides uh Evelyn sorry
um so given that my first permanent paid
employment was at City polls
um I feel that what we're doing
in a way is trying to solve a problem
which is similar to the one that we've
just discussed
how people engage in recreational
activity has changed
um young people over the age of 16 have
access to motorized vehicles they're not
constructed to where they can go on a
bike
um there's a lot of other competing
activity but as a person who's worked in
a poll can I just say that the 14 to 20
year olds are the ones that you don't
want around if they've got no particular
purpose in mind because they are the
nuisance they are the ones that
um you know let's be honest about it
they they're not there to train they're
not there for
a Family Purpose there's the handful
that really like going to the polls to
hang out and enjoy themselves and like
the activity of swimming but there's the
other ones that just like to do belly
flops and bombs and all the rest of it
and get in the road of other people who
are really relaxing I'm not sure that
the fact that we can survey and assess
and evaluate which demographic is coming
is always the most helpful way to look
at how we attract people to our
facilities and
are the 14 to 20 year olds the ones we
actually want to be going into the polls
don't mean that they shouldn't be
swimming and learning to swim and
exercising and they're under um you know
water polo and
any of those other
water sports related things that can
happen and the poles are not good things
but
young bored people
around water is always my biggest fear
and the one thing that I noticed in this
report it did say that
um that they wanted more risk-taking
type of activity and to me that's an
alarm Bell that is not a positive when a
swimming pool is
as I mentioned in the same breath
because they're the people that run
around they're the people that push
other people in all those sorts of
things sorry I don't mean to be a Debbie
Downer about this but if we're doing
market research purely on getting people
to come and spend money in the cafe as
opposed to
providing the citizens of invercargill
with a quality experience at The Falls
maybe we're chasing the wrong
demographics
having having dropped a car load of 16
and 17 year olds at the pool at their
request to go Hydro sliding and play in
the Leisure Pool at the weekend
I'm sure I actually quite disagree with
that none of them participate in
organized Sports and they were all
um
a having fun but B I guess also learning
skills that are really important when
you live on an island nation
and if you have a look at the number of
drownings that happened in this country
last year a bit more aquatic activity
might be useful rare
um that's why one suggest actually I
absolutely understand where you're
coming from in your report and some of
the questions in my head that came out
when I was going through it was yes we
do we do need to engage in youth Council
because youth know what youth want it's
really important that they don't get
missed out in this um collection of
information the other thing too is
um
foreign
about the youth at Kmart and targeting
them to come back to Spanish Palace and
potentially for the food side and and
interest levels like that I'd be more
inclined to want to see a quarter
leadership
um we have a sports um then now with
water polo and other sports that are
coming quite fashionable at the moment
as we see more leaders move throughout
our Nationwide Sports coverage so I
think it's really important to
um capitalize of that interest and yes
as Darren said and others have said we
are concerned about our drowning rates
whether it be in pools or outside so I
really think we need to focus on how do
we actually one engage in youth so that
it's meaningful to turn it into
leadership for water safety and
Leadership with it in the poll when you
talk about more risk adverse I'm kind of
of the generation where television gives
you those programs whether like the
water Warriors and they jump over those
big things and do all sorts of really
amazing scary ears activities I'm kind
of thinking that maybe that's what they
are meaning you know like the Australian
Gladiators and warriors water sports
it's really dangerous and our Splash
Palace isn't even set up to actually
have anything like that at the moment so
I guess that's future building as well
and lastly
um sorry
um
foreign
but yes I do think that
um
engaging in the 13 to 25 year old we've
got to realize that their needs in our
community have changed as well they are
online at home in their rooms watching
TV introverts not extroverts so we've
got to make sure that our services
aren't running the risk of wanting to
have them there but not actually have
the numbers to support long-term
um I guess investment in this area too
we have had inflatable obstacle courses
they're not quite Australian Ninja
Warrior
category but Trish that's for you chair
um sorry Evelyn I'm going to totally
disagree with you I think I think Splash
Palace at a right time is just the place
for bombs and the kind of things that
people have done in rivers and have got
access to which some of our kids don't I
I would love to see people be there
taking some risks you know but a Ninja
Warrior type stuff because I think
that's what that's what they're looking
for I mean I don't know but I I
certainly think we should consider that
uh he organized a bomb competition there
yeah through YouTube we've held several
money competitions uh the last one
recently even spent at the end of the
October holidays which is and when we
talk about risk averse it's it's about
letting them do stuff in a controlled
and Safe Way yeah so then they're taking
a risk but it's actually done safely
um we've got trained um staff who can
who can deal with anything and control
those environments
um yeah so
I was just going to say that look we've
got a invercargill city council
Community facility that we want the
community to use we've got here
identified a group that is not using it
in the way we might have expected and
some sensible ideas about how we might
actually explore that improve it find
that some of those ideas don't work or
really work well and can be developed
but to me
um it's the way I would feel about
um my library facility if my library
facility was no longer attracting
the sage group to it you would look for
ways in which your community facility
could reach out in a way that was not
being done
and get your staff and the people you're
trying to actually involve involved in
that I actually read this and thought
it's a good start it's not the answer to
everything but it's a good start on
involving a part of the community that
we've identified as not using a facility
we want to be used so I'm I'm interested
in seeing it start and getting a report
back on on how it's looking in six
months 12 months you know have we
succeeded have we found some ideas that
don't really work have we discovered
that zorbs have become the most popular
thing Nationwide and we need a few of
them
um yeah I I just think it's it's the
start of
making their Community facilities work
for the whole community and this
particular one we're very proud of we've
even got a forward plan for having a
second poll
we want to know that it's being used by
all our communities so I'm actually
quite excited by the ideas
let's settle in are you moving the three
motions
many guys you have to do that with uh
apania was Etsy thank you ring
um look my question is more about the
origin of the report this is in the
background part of what we have here
that you went to the Vodafone Vodafone
foundation and asked them to do a report
now
um are they like I'm completely blank on
the Vodafone Foundation do they support
young people
activities and stuff like that and are
they this was obviously people by them
uh through YouTube yes it was paid
through through paid for through them
and I believe that they're doing some
youth engagement work
um through the foundation right for for
invercargill or for anywhere I believe
that's
um throughout New Zealand no no Alex can
you help absolutely um a bit for the
last two minutes thank you
um so the
um thriving modihoku uh contestable
funding is up to four hundred thousand
dollars at the moment for available for
youth services or attracting rangatahi
into
um
basically in life not everybody starts
on an even playing field and while
that's true for a lot of Youth in New
Zealand it's exponentially truer for
um 12 to 25s uh in invercargill
um experiencing disadvantage exclusion
or locked out of opportunity by things
that they simply can't control and a
really good example of that is our slash
facility for people
um that would rather for example have
gender-neutral bathrooms that's
something out of their control that the
our current establishment doesn't allow
for them so it's trying to identify and
support ways that our youth have told us
or will tell us from the ground up how
they would prefer to engage with us and
how they would prefer to use their
facilities so a really key thing to
remember here is that you quite rightly
brought up councilor pottinger this is
paid for by the Vodafone Foundation they
have gone to the 12 to 25 year olds to
ask us what oh sorry ask them how they
want to put swipe with us rather than us
telling them
what to do from the top down and it's up
to us really now whether or not we
Implement some of those things that
they've requested
um and think I'm really thankful that
they have like I know that we've spoken
about risk this afternoon but risk to
young people can look like being an
Azure ball or jumping off the diving
board or
um you know getting over that fear of
heights by going off the top one or
being in a blacked out uh Hydra slide
going down backwards or something in a
safe controlled environment that's
supervised that doesn't just have people
wandering around the streets
um you might so my question was purely
around the origin and the funding and
the you know the care that obviously the
interesting Foundation has in youth so
that leads me to our previous item with
our sport fields and everything is this
something that the Vodafone Foundation
would be interested in and obviously
it's youth without a doubt
um with sports Fields
um and we've already everyone said that
it's a changing world people don't play
sport anymore is this something that we
should we be engaging with the Vodafone
Foundation about
obviously not you but we're still in the
sports Field Report just to say hey look
this is a lot bigger than just a piece
of turf
Traders there any relevance for that
report
I will have to come back to you uh
counselor because Mr gibbling is not
here today and he would be the resident
expert in this area if you're
comfortable I will take that question
and come back to the committee I just
see the two things as being linked even
though even though people don't agree
with that and they have different
chickens with different eggs I still
think they are linked
okay there are three recommendations
especially that we received this report
the uh Splash Palace design thinking
youth project report from Vodafone and
recognize those barriers and ask for
some options
so it's been moved by councilor so but
we have a second disciplined Pioneer
sorry I'll put that then all in favor
aye aye against
carried thanks Steve
thank you that brings us to the
activities report
foreign
anything you'd like to highlight from
these things
uh just to all the committee members
this will be the first time you've seen
this for the community wellbeing
committee so for many of you so just to
help you understand this is an activity
report so you can get an understanding
of what may be going on in the
background here at Council it provides
an overview of both a customer and
environment team in the Leisure and
Recreation team
we welcome any questions and if you have
any feedback or you would like to see
some different items presented on
that is all welcomed by ourselves Trudy
can I just ask one of one of the parts
of the report was about the burned out
vehicles at Sandy Point already Beach
there's a chance sometimes to issue
infringement notices if you're able to
find out if they've still lived event
yes under the letter act
um but how do we find these people and
what's the cost to us as a council I
can't give you the detailed cost at my
fingertips I can find that out but uh
the team have ways and means but if they
can't get the bin it does make it or the
registration plate it makes it very
difficult it is a costly exercise I
understand from last year some work that
was done at King cost us up to three to
five thousand dollars depending on the
vehicle but I can come back with
absolute costs
so it's not cost recovery no Barry yeah
I was reading the ODT today and I've
caught someone for burning all those
vehicles
so I hope he gets his just deserves
[Laughter]
we'll leave that in the hands of the
um law enforcement in the courts
cost recovery is always a challenge
uh look my questions regarding the Civic
Theater and I guess it's uh
when we get when do we get the Victoria
rooms back
or obviously we are making you know
obviously it's a good tenant in there
they're paying
um but I just wondered is there a is
there an indicated time frame around
this or
I don't have that information but I will
email I just just purely here I will
find out that
um answer to that I thought the stage
vaccination program starts to wind down
from the end of November
and lots of venues there'll be still
some regular health providers that are
able to conduct
that but
um for what's going on in there over the
past 12 months that's already scaled
down I'm using about half the size
oh it's just one of our important venues
you know for for weddings and stuff uh
we probably get Richard to come back
with somebody yeah that's okay I just I
just noticed it was still open when I
walked past
Crush three two I'm interested in the
food foraging how much does that used
so was I counselor um I don't have that
information
but I will find that out for you I it
would be I guess challenging for the
community to be aware of it
and I will come back to you on that
thank you very much Evelyn and Leslie
might be able to assist oh I was just
going to say that Parks do um promote
when when they have harvesting days and
the medical Kai Collective does as well
um so I think the answer is that it is
well utilized and people
um I mean I know I noticed as I walk
around the places where those
um
our plantings are
not my idea of gardening but I
understand the use of the space and and
the benefit that it provides so yeah
like I'll just add a few if you've ever
seen some of the areas after the
harvesting days you will notice that
they have been extremely popular in a
very well used there's no doubt at all
it's been it's been a great Innovation
to see and I slightly disagree with
Evelyn because I actually like it as a
form of gardening and in fact encourage
it a lot more for instance the um self
alive fruit and nut group who's planted
so many fruits and nut trees that all
those harvesting opportunities and the
fact that our parks department got
involved to that extent I think has been
really useful as a community initiative
I didn't realize I'm sorry that they
were particularly Harvest days I thought
you could just go along and get
now pick them whenever you like I don't
think anybody objects if you do it okay
unlike the flowers
[Laughter]
when there is some objection
if you forget to brush the dirt off the
bottom yes rangi obviously that that
food foraging and harvesting doesn't
include the wildlife behind the fences
is that right
behind the defenses is hardly Wildlife
it is life it's pretty tight
yeah it's a delicious looking alpaca
Grant uh just with regard to the
conscience that's a pretty good number
so well done um I know it's a really
important piece of work that we do so
that's great
um it the relativity to other councils
like our clearance rate would be above
average nationally um thank you
councilor the team have worked really
hard nationally in the building consent
area they are doing really really well
in the recent irons audit came through
one of the fastest I've been involved in
and uh they said how well our team are
working together as one Council and in
terms of the non-notified resource
consents that's been a work in progress
and that's the great work of the manager
and the team leaders involved in
bringing those consents up
correct it was an area of concern if we
wound back the clock maybe 12 months but
the staff have made some tremendous
progress over there yeah I think we need
to acknowledge that it's very good thank
you
any other questions or observations
through the activities report Leslie
thanks Mr chair it's not a question it's
an observation I just wanted to make a
comment about the tatapu otane
opening
um for those who missed that because of
course it took place in September before
the local body elections
um that's that's been an enormously
successful project and I can't recommend
highly enough that people go and have a
look at that even if you never saw that
city council area before this project
you will notice just the enormous
difference the project has made to
what's happening out there
I just I just see it going on in Leaps
and Bounds it's been really positive and
the fact that our Park staff were so
involved in the evolution of that area I
think is a real tribute to to parks and
the fact that parks are prepared to take
those initiatives and run with really
good projects that that have good
prospects of success so I really just
wanted to compliment really the whole
project and the park stuff playing such
a large path and and just recommend
everybody go and have a look at just
what's developed out there and and the
fact that it is so positive for the
future because of that training aspect
as well
actually it's a good point
um
along with Leslie I was the other
counselor who attended that opening and
it was really interesting to see how
passionate and proud the staff were that
we allowed them to take part in the
process and how much they've learned and
enjoyed sharing information and if you
did the
bus tour we had that or no vehicle tour
that we had there maybe nine months ago
you just about wouldn't recognize the
place but for those that are going on
the bus tour whenever it is in the next
couple of weeks uh this is one of the
areas we'll be covering off so you'll
have a chance to see it firsthand
Evelyn
um just picking up on the woods store
at Queen's Park
noting that
um Parts have
um removed a number of trays that
we're at the end of their life
um
without having to be compelled by a
windstorm event
um
can we have an update from them please
on how they're progressing with the
at-risk
you know aging tree population that we
have because there's a couple of places
as I walk that I think oh these trees
are actually older than me
um
how how risky is it for people who live
in those well I'm 70 toes so
so I'm not sure there was a way out of
it
getting picked in The Shins sorry no no
I but just if if
they'd be large have been around for
that period of time
how many of them should be we be
thinking about replacing and I know that
Parks have been looking at this but I
can't remember how long ago it is since
we had an update could we have another
update about certainly we can arrange
that for the next committee right again
Leslie
um like the the parks department have a
policy on the trees and the danger and
it's constantly involved over the last
12 years on Council they are right on it
and it's quite the opposite actually
when they come to do responsible felling
the public it's all up in arms and the
way you chopping these trees down
because obviously you you get a block of
trees and you've got a few bad ones but
if you take them out it puts the other
ones at more risk so it's a real science
to it and I would soon leave it to the
experts than rather
yeah there are arborists who are looking
at it Leslie
I think I was just going to say that the
tree playing
but he hasn't seen it that's almost an
individual blow-by-blow tree
plan
um it's well worth looking at and I
certainly have every confidence that
over the years that's developed into a
really expert plan that's
probably since I was first on Council
and there were a few trees we were
worried about we now know exactly where
all those trees are and their lifespan
and which ones we should be looking at
taking down at which time so yeah I'm
I'm
very happy if that treatment well mostly
there was one that caught us out last
week Tom then Berry
I I apologize I think I'm a slow thinker
and everybody else cheers because I'm
going to take you back again to the
previous conversation about
um
of course I'm going to mess or something
and I so I I was going to ask an
embarrassing question I don't know who
that is
um and I thought look at my so I looked
at the newspaper article that was
referred to Nicole and it doesn't say in
there either
so I I really just wonder the the extent
to which there's well if I know nothing
about it
um the extent to which does it there's
really been enough information and
provided I know that we own the line we
don't own the ICC owns the land but we
don't own the project but so I don't
know if this is addressed to the project
it addressed to us but maybe it'll be
that no because nobody knows what it is
McIver Road nursery uh most most of the
mainstream media were there covering it
uh Barry then grunt
yeah I was playing a uh Invitational
Tournament at north end on Friday and
there's a whole row of trees between the
museum and the club rooms and some of
the limb uh leaning over quite bad
and I don't think they're going to take
care of old Museum down but they'll take
a few people with them
right uh just what we've shown the cost
of the wood removal but we must have
made some money in terms of selling the
Tomato wheat
hopefully yes I get chipped up and used
for something
yeah I know some of it's millable
somewhere you'd like a report back well
no not Sarah report but I think it's
important that we show the balance and
it just because it cost us but there's
been some income recovery as well
on information coming back uh you can
update us on the Vic rooms I can uh so
through you Mr chair so I've got an
update from the staff at the Civic that
the lease currently goes until the 31st
of December they're currently working
with the
um leasi to understand if that's going
to be extended or whether that will
cease early and they'll know in the next
few weeks
no thanks Trudy so would we have people
you know obviously planning a wedding in
advance just wondering perhaps that
they're queued up
in my experience uh the team are really
good at looking at different options
that are available for innocence back
yeah weddings well for weddings because
you can use other parts of the Civic as
well yeah um or other facilities and uh
they will work as closely as they can to
fulfill the customer's needs yeah I
think it's going to be great for your
staff if they have some clarity to say
either way
thanks
thanks Council has any other questions
or comments on the activities report
the most thorough amount of questions
and comments we've had on the activities
report yet well done awesome
I would simply like to move that the
reporters received Evelyn Andrea thank
you I'll put that all in favor against
carried and there being no other items
of General business I will thank you for
your attendance and close this meeting
but wait there's more and the stream can
remain on as well because we've got a
workshop coming up
having a look at
um
some of the data an economic update
and Brad Olson I think is taking that as
well close five do you need five minutes
so the meeting's closed we need 15
minutes just to prepare and then we'll
and we'll resume the Stream
and start the workshop at 4 15.
Professor welcome to attend that as well
if you wish
um
cool spider
what's